nous pensons que Mark a une autre maîtresse et
nous allons aller la trouver
quoi
et et que comptez-vous faire exactement
si vous trouvez cette fille un jour à la
fois opération
et aujourd'hui c'est le jour de la reconnaissance légère la cible
est en mouvement la
cible est en mouvement  d'accord je ne peux pas
croire que tu n'es pas du tout intéressé par ça
elle se lève oh oh mon dieu
qu'est ce que tu penses qu'elle a fait
qu'elle n'a pas eu ça
quand tu as un corps comme ça
elle est comme les
dix tartes au citron parfaites double d évidemment tu
sais ce que
tu dis à un moment donné je joue bien au
tennis mais si je joue contre
ron mcenroe alors je m'attends à perdre tu
sais de quel droit
je suis mcenroe qu'est ce que tu
fais